We have seen a RAW based processor, but this processor has not been
a superscalar processor. It was only issuing one instruction per cycle, and
even though we have seen a variant in one of the quizzes that commits up
to two instructions per cycle, the bottom link will still be the issue.
So now let's look at a real superscalar processor. What does it have to do?
First, it needs to fetch more than one instruction per cycle. When we
are really fetching more than one instructions worth of memory per cycle. So
if the instructions are for example four bites and we want to fetch two,
our fetch really needs to supply us with eight bits every cycle.
Then, we need to decode more than one instruction per cycle.
This amounts to basically having more than one decoder.
So, every cycle the first decoder will be looking at the first instruction,
while the second one will be looking at the second instruction we fetched, etc.
Next, we have to issue more than one instruction per cycle.
Remember that we need to issue instructions in order.
So every cycle, we will consider the next instruction that should issue for
issuing. And if it can issue, we will also consider the next instruction, and
if that one can issue, we will consider the next one, and so on.
So for example, if you were trying to issue up to three instructions per cycle,
they still need to be three consecutive instructions, and
if one of them cannot issue, then the following ones cannot issue either.
We want to be able to dispatch more than one instruction per cycle.
We have seen that if we have more than one execution unit,
we actually can dispatch one instruction to each of the units. Effectively,
we will already able to dispatch more than one instruction per cycle. Now,
the problem usually is that you have many more adds than multiplies for
example. So if you really want to finish more than one instruction per cycle and
do that over many cycles, probably we would have to have something like two add
units and a multiplication unit so that even if we have only adds to
do we would be able to issue and dispatch two per cycle on average.
Then we need to be able to broadcast more than one result per cycle.
This involves not having only two broadcast passes or three broadcast passes but
also every reservation station has to compare it's tags that it's waiting for
to every one of the passes because in any given cycle we could have any of
the passes producing a result. So, this immensely complicates the reservation
station. Basically the cost of each reservation station is
proportional to the number of broadcasts we have to monitor. If we had one,
let's say that's some cost, having three broadcasting sets is going to be at
least three times as costly. And finally our commit logic needs to be capable of
committing more than one instruction per cycle. We have already seen in one
of our quizzes that this is very similar to issuing in that for committing,
we consider the first instruction that is not committed for commit. It that one
can't commit, we consider the next one to commit in the same cycle, and so
on. So, it's not only that we have to consider three instructions for commit and
check whether they're done, we also have to make sure that we don't commit for
example, the third instruction we are considering unless both of
the previous ones are committed. And among these we really have to
be worried about the weakest link. Meaning if we can fetch up to let's say
four instructions per cycle, decode up to four instructions per cycle,
issue only one per cycle, dispatch up to four, broadcast up to four,
and commit up to four, we will still be limited by the issue of only one. So on
average we can never produce more than one instruction finishing per cycle and
committing, because simply they have to go through issue one at a time. If all
of these are very, very large, and one of them is limited to let's say three,
then again, we will not be able to average more than three instructions per
cycle, no matter how well the programming is managed in this organization. So,
pretty much this is kind of like a pipe where the width of the pipe in each of
the stage, is determining the flow of the entire pipe pretty much. The narrowest
place in the pipe is what limits the flow of the instructions through it.